non pourquoi
tu bosses ténu qui opèrent à des
chômeurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en ai marre de cette histoire je veux
la vie d'une seule et unique personne de
qui il est en colère qui çà et là ce
soir thierry rogers texan faire l'amour
roger damour
[Applaudissements]
ça peut commencer bien sûr lui qui me
déçoit le plus c'est bon pas les
attaquer un pays il est d'origine
d'alsace
y est ils l'invitent delphine à manger
chaque fois tac des pièces ms
n'aurait-on métier
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé c'était mon frère c'est
vrai ils s'entendent très bien à chaque
fois mais oui je vais j'ai deux places
dans la voiture
et puis l'histoire de laponie amène
alors que jamin benjamin franchement m'a
déçu quand je suis arrivé ici à trois
ans avec delphine c'est la première
personne connue avec qui j'ai fait un
selphy une photo dallas est une
célébrité et là ils l'ont bois ils
envoient des messages tout ça j'ai dit à
delphine delphine tu peux pas avoir un
truc avec ce mec on a ces dettes c'est
bon
[Rires]
à
cela dit le shérif
voilà perdus
voilà
[Applaudissements]
tous trouvent t3 surnom si tu étais une
star du x
la saucisse de strasbourg
fibres de boulbi et guillaume la tob
thiel
perdre
pourquoi
faire des choix
[Applaudissements]
c'est transforme en frankenstein
va d'une non mais ça va pas bien
vous êtes là on n'est pas
rationnel tu veux de l'eau j'en remercie
mais j'ai dit mais je leur donne oui
volontiers tu vois quelque chose tu me
fais pas quel peut-être un truc ici à
toi tu un truc à grignoter un bref ça
c'est mon nom perso à me faire du bien
l'hôte écolo c'est
à cette attention
j'allais découvrir cette nouvelle
émission danse avec le roi du qatar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sachez que ce qui va se passer là est
fait par des professionnels
surtout
refaites pas ça chez vous bien entendu
voilà c'est important de le signaler
merci à vous qui nous regardent et fait
attention à ce qu'on dit on est très
content de recevoir un ben moi aussi
à la fac manifeste pas ce
problème là pour moi on est partis au
resto
on ne peut pas danser
tu vois comme chez moi foschi but les
médias le public attend
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
candice est ce que vous pouvez trouver
les mots il nous reste trois minutes
après voilà c'est terminé mais il faut
il faut travailler
je verrai ce que tu as alors tentons pas
là la beauté je ne sais pas je suis
bloqué ou dans le milieu on dit va
frérot tu t'es fier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu peux lire
la super 7 %
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais sans cyril à
mon porte-bonheur civile mais bukavu l'a
vu dans votre poche patron charmante
j'aime beaucoup son humour et son
autodérision laissez vous conduire
demain non c'est sincèrement
et
[Applaudissements]
l'audi elodie c'est un incroyable et je
voudrais dire elodie je te jure côté
terne exemple je le pense vraiment c'est
un rayon de soleil c'est si tu souris
toujours
les téléspectateurs te connaître nos bus
raconte nous un peu ton histoire c'était
une histoire incroyable et elodie je
vous dis moi je suis fan absolu sont là
dort ici est un talent incroyable mais
j'ai participé à un télé crochet je sais
personne je sais je sais pas je connais
un petit peu
c'est un petit peu dans le dur
on a un petit peu dans l'individu alors
j'ai sorti depuis deux singles
exactement grâce aux réseaux sociaux
grâce à l'amour des gens ça cartonne
pourtant et ça marche et ça marche très
bien ce moment
j'ai fait 600 km bah oui c'est pas pour
un tout il faut les faire des
gaspillages sont le coeur un
pratiquement siriman baba mon nid
douillet avec toi j'aime sourire à la
vie car tu es doux comme une mélodie
peu importe nos différences et nos
chemins d'avant si avec toi je dansais
je vais dollar en
devient mon couscous
c'est enfin tu doutes je ne te dis
baisse pas les bras toi et moi pour la
vie on combattra l'ennui le soleil après
la plus haut
alors
je tente
merci merci et l'eau
je connais beaucoup dans la rue depuis
mai face à ce genre de vol oui au regard
des oui non oui c'est vrai que je suis
pas non plus dit là dessus mais c'est
lady
mary mais on reconnaît je fais des
photos et du genre les gens sont
toujours super gentil donc voilà oui ça
se passe guère apprécié les réseaux des
fois ça un peu dur mais bon ça même toit
les raisons il ya du bon et du mauvais
il ya des gens sur les réseaux qui de ce
type moi je prends le bon matin sont là
bien sûr mais bon ça colle bon mais
c'est vrai car beaucoup de m aussi un
serait vraiment pas que les réseaux et
c'est difficile face est difficile de si
on est un peu fragile ou quoi ça peut
être ça peut être compliqué quand je
veux dire mais moi je suis forte donc
mais il nous manque un petit peu de
succès une différence ces gens et ces
attaques où est la différence quand il
ya des gens qui te t'attaques sûreté
différence sur les réseaux oui bien sûr
synchro l'handicap ça différemment sur
sur le talent heures en sursis mais
pourquoi la cie pourquoi ça qu'ils
trouvent à redire sur tout bon aussi moi
je prends le bond tous âges pour
l'amender elle reste seule pas su quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]